Here, a equals negative 3. Amazing work if you found this solution. This
problem is a lot like the ones we've seen before. We want to move this radical
to the other side of the equal sign. We do that by adding the square root of a
plus 12 to both sides. Next we square both sides of the equation to undo these
square roots. This gives us a linear equation of 2a plus 15 equals a plus 12.
Next, we subtract a from both sides to get a plus 15 equals positive 12. Then
we subtract 15 from both sides to isolate a, so a equals negative 3. Finally,
we check our a value of negative 3 by replacing a in the original equation with
that value. On the left-hand side of our equation, this simplifies to root 9
minus root 9. We know this is 0, or we could say 3 minus 3, which also equals
0. This means our solution checks so we have our answer.